in the early 20s a recession swept
across the country
resulting in the closure of many plants
and factories thousands were left
jobless
people relocated to larger cities in the
hopes that more opportunities could be
found
but unemployment numbers far exceeded
the positions that were available
poorer communities with cheaper housing
began to swell and gangs offered these
people a way to survive
and feed their families with the
downfall of government infrastructure
these groups only further expanded
claiming whole neighborhoods and zones
as their territory
with little resistance from the
government and mega corporations
in this video we'll be covering some of
the gangs that could be found in night
city
in cyberpunk 2077
[Music]
[Music]
hailing from night city's industrial
zone the maelstrom are cruel
violent and deadly individuals they have
an intense fascination with the net
and cyber technologies the fixation with
cybertech
comes from the desire to improve their
bodies through extensive modifications
by replacing the weak outer shell of
human flesh with something far superior
with such strong beliefs their
philosophy is often dictated by their
obsessions
an ideology that all living things
including people are frail
and inferior however as a consequence
and in their eyes and acceptable risk
many of their members
suffer from cyber psychosis or are on
the verge of developing it
a mental illness brought on by an
overload of cybernetic enhancements
where an individual loses their identity
as a human and start to relate more
with machines than people the gang is
split into a number of different groups
who work around the industrial district
of watson
each cell is responsible for a
particular part of their operation
jobs such as raids assassinations and
protecting valuable goods
can be as large as 30 members other jobs
like running of patrols
usually only involve four or five
identified mainly for their cyber optic
implants and subdermal plating
giving them an almost mechanical zombie
apocalypse appearance
the black metallic tattoos hinted their
strange beliefs and their prosthetic
limbs are built purely for combat
by smuggling illegal drugs and
medications maelstrom has a profitable
source of income
and they seem to have a particular
interest in the drug trifet
heavily guarded transport vehicles are
often also a target
and no match for the gang's well-planned
and executed heists
they also enjoy carrying out
assassinations and their methods are
often performed in crude grotesque ways
it's incredibly common to find one of
their many victims drowned in wet cement
dismembered and or skinned alive
another significant source of income is
the toten tans club
the most popular gangsters drink and
riot venue in the city
with its death metal sounds and its
party hard mantra this club located an
abandoned factory
is the place to be any night where the
body count is less than a dozen is
considered a dull knight
be warned though if you don't respect
the customs and the authority of the
maelstroms
you will be eliminated in one of the
more painful ways imaginable
there are also unconfirmed rumors that
the gang is somehow involved in the
production of black market brain dance
records
these veer towards the more bizarre and
disturbing types of brain dances
other products that they allegedly
produce are records of numbness
this places users in a strange void
state of mind
which is popular with over-stimulated
brain dance users
the scavengers are callous low-life scum
who prey on the ignorant
and seemingly unaware people of night
city
as the cyber technology industry
continued to grow body augmentation
became more available to the masses
this technology didn't just become a way
of replacing lost limbs and damaged
organs
it became a way of enhancing the
limitation of the human body
[Music]
as you would expect this came at a
reasonable financial cost
in a place like night city where the
rich co-exists so closely to the poor
it didn't take long before an entire
underground industry was set up
which involved stealing the cybertech
and then selling it on the black market
and this is where the scaves come in
with absolutely no regard for human life
they see others as a walking paycheck
just waiting to be plucked off the
street and harvested
this business of pulling people apart
and selling them off piece by piece
is a messy business but is hugely
profitable
the scavs are ruthless and immoral and
their methods are far from sophisticated
but they have no problems getting their
hands dirty to make a quick buck
the scavengers don't have a set turf as
such they're spread across the city
they tend to form small groups with
little or no hierarchy or structure
despite their lack of organized
structure scavenger groups are
definitely not to be disregarded
or taken lightly they won't hesitate in
making a horrific example
of anyone who gets in their way
scavengers can be recognized by their
track suits and criminal tattoos
[Music]
assault abduction mutilation and
dismemberment
at the scavenger's trademark the gang
has achieved complete ownership of the
body parts after market
since their customers would rather pay
for human organs and second-hand
cyberware
then start pulling people apart
themselves
the victims can often never be found
because the scavs tend to utilize every
part of the body
any harvested cyberware and organs are
placed directly onto the black market
and leftovers are either dumped or
burned the scavengers are the main
supplier of low end illegal cyberware
for other gangs
small town criminals and shady river
docks
they are also frequently hired to
perform unpleasant or inconvenient tasks
by clients who are unwilling to do it
themselves
basically if there is money on offer the
scans will take the job
regardless of what it is no questions
asked
one of the largest gangs in night city
the valentinos
run a large majority of poverty-stricken
neighborhoods
districts such as vista del ray haywood
and glen are predominantly latino and
being a territorial gang
this is where their roots run deep
within the community
with the majority of valentino members
being of mexican descent
they are the embodiment of the chicano
culture and night city
having cultivated these traditions for
more than a century they place great
value on justice
honor and brotherhood although this
doesn't mean that they're not open to
other ethnic groups from joining them
and these people tend to integrate
quickly into their culture and customs
this also holds true when it comes to
local communities with a loyalty working
both ways
their sense of shared heritage binds
them together essentially forming one
big happy family
so unsurprisingly any attempt by police
or corporate entities to infiltrate the
valentinos
is almost impossible betrayal by a gang
member is among the most heinous crimes
a valentino can commit
and is usually punishable by a
particularly gruesome death
on the other hand valentinos who died
fighting for their cause
are often remembered as martyrs and are
commemorated in song
and depicted on large murals complete
with written descriptions
of the saints glorious deeds
valentino's members openly display their
gang tattoos
gold jewelry and religious insignia they
have a preference for colourful clothing
modified low riders and custom-made gold
and silver-plated guns
the valentino's owned many legitimate
businesses including restaurants
auto shops and nightclubs along with
brain dancing recording studios
and local construction companies however
some of these are used for criminal
activity
such as money laundering meeting places
or chop shops for stolen vehicles
their main source of income is gun
smuggling car theft
drug trafficking robbery hit jobs
prostitution
and illegal modification of weapons and
vehicles
an unusual and mysterious gang from
pacifica with a dark reputation for
their netrunning skills
and mystical voodoo presence
because of their nature and the lack of
any police forces in the pacifica
district
it's difficult to gain any hard
information about the voodoo boy's
numbers
structure or even their goals
it's speculated to consist entirely of
those from a haitian blood
they are an exclusive secretive gang and
are completely distrustful of strangers
no outsider has successfully infiltrated
the gang
the gang was originally made up of
voodoo priests and priestesses
but in 2062 climate change which
resulted in widespread
natural disasters around the globe
completely wiped haiti
off the face of the planet and the gang
became the self-appointed guardians of
the haitian refugees interests
and safety in the pacifica combat zone
the voodoo boys have no fixed
headquarters even the location and time
for each meeting
is chosen at the end of the previous one
at least two high-profile medias have
died while trying to cover this game
they are considered a priority for the
night city police department
and are known as being violent and
dangerous
the terror they inspire has been
successful in keeping the local
merchants quiet
and uncooperative with police
it's widely known that the gang is
devoted to uncovering the secrets of the
old net
and it's believed that they are
searching for rogue intelligence systems
that live beyond the barrier they're
also edge runners
breaking every rule that there is break
and programming viruses
that can freeze neural networks these
activities have earned the voodoo boys
the attention of nitwatch
an organization tasked with policing the
net
most voodoo boys are netronis so cooling
suits and neural implants
are common elements to each member's
outfit with the addition of more
culturally specific
voodoo flavoured elements like
dreadlocks tattoos
and the bones and skulls of small birds
and rodents that they were as charms
the gang's primary criminal activities
involve the hacking of data banks
and accounts within various corporations
in search of restricted and top-secret
data
they consistently violate netwatch laws
and regulations
the voodoo boys also hire themselves out
as mercenary netrunners
for private contractors who are
interested in hit and run net running
operations
who are exploring the forgotten and
ruined parts of the old net
other sources of income are hard to
verify but theft of virtual currency
and information is likely among them
so this was part two of my gangs of
night city coverage
if you missed the first one it'll be
linked in the end screen
otherwise i know cyberpunk isn't one of
those games i usually cover
but i'm really looking forward to this
title and the vast background of lore
behind it only furthers this
like i've always said i do since i first
started making content for youtube
if i'm not enjoying it i won't cover it
and currently
the other games just don't have a lot
for me to talk about right now
it doesn't mean i've stopped playing
them i'm just having a break playing
other games
but don't worry that tom clancy universe
is a special place for me
i'll be keeping a close eye on things
waiting for the next updates and
releases to be announced
anyway thank you very much for watching
i really do appreciate those of you who
tune into the new content i push out
it means a lot cheers
[Music]
you